c'est bon ouais allongée c'est bon ce
soir s'achève la présidence la plus
lamentable de la vème république qui
aura détruit pratiquement toute
confiance autour d'elle mais une
nouvelle fois en dépit de tout par
l'abstention les bulletins blancs et
nuls comme par les votes au nom de
monsieur macron notre pays a massivement
refusé l'extrême droite car elle est
étrangère à l'identité républicaine de
la france
madame le pen arrive la troisième de ce
deuxième tour après monsieur macron les
abstentions les bulletins blancs et nuls
le nouveau président est élu la
courtoisie et l'amour de notre
démocratie
comment d'en prendre acte sans
barguigner et de lui présenter nos voeux
puisse le sens du destin de notre patrie
vous habitez monsieur le président et la
pensée des démunis sans droit sans toit
sans emploi vous obséder puisse la
france y trouvait son compte mais mieux
vaudrait y veiller par nous mêmes le
programme du nouveau monarque
présidentiel est connu c'est la guerre
contre les acquis sociaux du pays et
l'irresponsabilité écologique
nous n'y sommes pas condamnés les
élections législatives doivent montrer
qu'après un vote de refus et de peur le
moment est venu d'un choix positif le
choix de l'avenir en commun j'appelle
les 7 millions de personnes qui se sont
regroupées autour du programme dont j'ai
été le candidat à se mobiliser et à
rester unis qu'elle est ou non voter
pour monsieur matheron j'appelle tous
ceux qui sont prêts à rompre avec le
passé à se joindre à la france insoumise
dont nous avons fait le nouveau
mouvement de masse en tête dans tant de
villes de notre pays
fédérer vous les gens sans vous
éparpillez puisque vous avez vu comment
à 600 mille voix près vous avez été
éliminé 2
2e tour fédérer vous si vous vous
reconnaissez dans l'humanisme écologique
et sociale qui est nécessaire à notre
temps et dont je m'efforce d'être le
porte parole
les gens ne lâchez rien ne renoncer à
rien ce pays et les gens simples qui le
peuple ne sont condamnés ni au pouvoir
des riches ni à celui des haineux une
nouvelle majorité parlementaire est
possible autour de nous le goût du
bonheur reste contagieux à notre appel
le 18 juin deuxième tour des
législatives
notre résistance peut gagner la bataille
et je vais m'y employer avec vous de
toute mon énergie
vive la république vive la france